[Musique]
il
eh bien vous retrouver aujourd'hui avec
cette envie irrésistible de relever
notre pays cette france des territoires
des terroirs c'est une chance pour
l'avenir les paysans du doubs sont
contentes vous accueilli l année ce
matin enfin mozilla
j'ai la conviction que notre pays il
reste en outre mieux s'ils étaient
guidés par les valeurs des hommes et des
femmes de la terre le travail le courage
c'est un métier de passion l'envi l'envi
d'entreprendre le sursaut de notre
agriculture viendra aussi les robes
digne que nous donnerons à nous à
l'éditeur est beau
mais il sait aussi qu'on puisse laisser
leurs chars y payer des factures à tout
le monde des décalages parce qu'on ne
pouvait pas financièrement oui ah oui
les hauts et des bas il ya eu des hauts
et des bas en nylon les charges contre
lui donc on a des gens il arrête la
production de care qui veut faire ou
peugeot assez de cette agri mashing
alors on voit jolis sapins aux
agriculteurs du doubs je passerai la vie
aching je resterai
[Musique]